le docteur sergio qu'un aveyron
directeur du groupe de neuromodulation
avancé en italie la prochaine étape a
déjà commencé l'équipe chinoise fait des
essais sur des cadavres parce que c'est
très important que l'équipe soit
totalement synchronisée il ya tellement
de gens de spécialistes impliqués qui
doivent être parfaitement coordonnés et
donc cette partie a déjà commencé avec
de bons résultats mais je suis confiant
que nous pouvons le faire sans aucun
problème
peu de scientifiques peuvent se
prononcer sur les techniques que se
propose d'utiliser le médecin italien
parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu accès aux
détails de sa méthode
ces expériences n'ont pas été publiés
n'ont plus en bonne et due forme dans
des revues scientifiques médicales
c'est pas du champ scientifique parce
que la science et cette expérience de
créativité et la réelle et réaliste des
patients qui font en grande souffrance
le docteur michel alade aminu chef du
service de chirurgie plastique ou centre
hospitalier de l'université de montréal
pour soigner des patients tétraplégiques
pour soigner des patients défigurés
c'est les faux espoir parce que là on
sort du domaine du rationnel pour aller
dans l'irrationnel et c'est un peu ce
que je reproche à la démarche
le branchement la connexion d'un moelle
épinière le branchement d'un ton nerveux
aussi important et reste un problème
technique majeur
l'équipe d'auteurs cannavaro a l'air
d'avoir une piste mais il a publié dans
aucun journal sérieux j'ai vu très peu
d'articles de ce docteur cannavaro donc
pas du tout pas du tout ce qui ressemble
à une très grosse équipe qui est public
près pas un gros projet scientifique et
aucun article sur cette technique
particulière un cappone un bios
techniciens du centre médical langone à
new york
s'interroge dans un récent éditorial sur
le fait de savoir pourquoi ce neurologue
italien qui prétend maîtriser la
réparation des moelle épinière ne traite
pas d'abord les dizaines de milliers de
patients paralysés dans le monde
la médecine est toujours impuissante et
même si une telle greffe était vraiment
possible
il faudra utiliser tellement de
médicaments disent des spécialistes pour
empêcher un rejet de l'organe que le
patient ne pourrait pas survivre bien
longtemps
ces traitements sont toxique à haute
dose il rit un arctique était sorti il
ya quelques années dans le british
journal
mais les flics qui expliquait que le que
qui comprenait un traitement qui rejette
toute sa vie et qu'on commençait à ces
jeunes
on avait une perte de durée de vie
d'environ une quinzaine d'années qui ont
commencé à l'âge de 30 ans
le premier homme à s'être porté
volontaire pour l'opération se nomme
valérie spiri 10 nov
âgé de 30 ans ce russe est atteint d'une
maladie rare qui a conduit à la
dégénérescence de sa moelle épinière et
c'est pour avoir la chance de marcher à
nouveau qu'il a décidé de se porter
volontaires l'intervention doit
consister à prélever sa tête tout en
préservant ses cellules cérébrales et
ses vaisseaux sanguins pour ensuite leur
connecté au coeur d'un donneur
le docteur sergio canavero directeur du
groupe de neuromodulation avancé de
turin en italie
valérie spiridonov c'est le patient
russe qui est le premier volontaire pour
la chirurgie si nous avons l'argent pour
valérie spiroudôme of en russie nous
pourrions le faire dans un an pas plus
pour le moment je m'en tiens à la non ce
que j'ai déjà fait que noël 2010 est
serait la date pour cette chirurgie si
jamais vous réussissiez en combien de
temps le patient pourrait retrouver
l'usagé de ses mains est ce que nous
savons de l'anatomie humaine et les
données que nous avons des expériences
animales
on estime que le patient resterait
endormi de deux à quatre semaines
il pourrait ensuite commencé la
physiothérapie et je prévois qu'en
quelques mois il ou elle pourrait
marcher
cette opération est non seulement d'une
extrême complexité mais elle peut aussi
entraîner une sérieuse réactions
psychologiques chez le patient s'il ya
deux fonctionné sur ce point un vin bio
engineering technology affirme que la
mise au point un système qui va
permettre au docteur canavero de mener à
terme la réhabilitation de son patient
d'après l'animation dévoilé le patient
serait maintenu debout à l'aide d'un
gilet et de sangles et on lui poserait
sur la tête un casque qui diffuseraient
des images en réalité virtuelle et qui
serait censé lui donner l'impression de
marcher à nouveau le traumatisme
psychique pourrait bien être plus
difficile à surmonter ultime ans que le
traumatisme physique donner plus de
force
à dire 20 pour affronter les gens le
regard des autres le regard des autres
ne voient plus autant qu'avant comme un
obstacle
en mai 2005 une jeune française isabelle
dinoire a été sauvagement mordu par un
chien et elle perdait ainsi la moitié
inférieure de son visage une équipe
française a réussi à lui greffer donc
cette partie du visage du triangle du
visage nez lèvres menton
une grève qui a réussi mais les
lendemains où plan psychologique ont été
très difficiles
michel lalande et nino se souvient de
cet événement avec le temps on a vu
qu'il y avait des problèmes importants
d'adaptation
alors là il s'agit même pas transformer
un visage et d'être en plein visage mais
toute une tête avec le cerveau donc ça
paraît fou là on va comme je vous dis là
j'ai l'impression qu'on on sort du champ
scientifique classique
un reportage de radio canada
international